C'est incroyable, quand vous rencontrez un chef d'Etat et que vous lui demandez,
"Quelle est votre ressource naturelle la plus précieuse ?" --
Ils ne répondront pas "Les enfants" en premier.
Et quand vous dites les enfants,
ils vont très vite tomber d'accord avec vous.
(Video) : Nous voyageons aujourd'hui avec
le ministre de la Défense de Colombie,
chef de l'armée et chef de la police,
et nous déposons 650 ordinateurs portables
aujourd'hui pour des enfants
qui n'ont ni télévision, ni téléphone
et ont vécu dans une communauté
coupée du reste du monde
pendant les 40 dernières années.
Ce qui est important dans le fait de fournir des ordinateurs portables dans cette région
est que cela connnecte des enfants qui ont été par ailleurs déconnectés
à cause des FARC,
la guérilla, qui a débuté il y a 40 ans
comme un mouvement politique et ensuite est devenu un mouvement de traffic de drogues.
Il y a un milliard d'enfants dans le monde,
et 50 pour cent d'entre eux n'ont pas l'électricité
à la maison ou à l'école.
Et dans certains pays - permettez-moi de prendre l'Afghanistan comme exemple --
75 pour cent des filles ne vont pas à l'école.
Et je ne veux pas dire qu'elles abandonnent l'école
en cours élémentaire ou en cours moyen - elles n'y vont pas.
Donc, dans les trois années qui se sont écoulées
depuis que j'ai parlé à TED et montré un prototype,
il est passé de simple idée
à un véritable ordinateur portable.
Nous avons un demi-million d'ordinateurs portables aujourd'hui
dans les mains d'enfants.
Nous en avons environ un quart de million en transit
en direction de ces enfants et d'autres enfants,
et puis il y a un quart de million de plus
qui sont en cours de commande en ce moment.
Ainsi, en gros, il y a un million d'ordinateurs portables.
C'est moins que ce que j'avais prédit --
J'avais prévu de trois à 10 millions --
mais c'est quand même un très grand nombre.
En Colombie, nous avons environ 3000 ordinateurs portables.
Voici le ministre de la Défense, avec qui nous travaillons,
pas le ministre de l'Education, car cette opération est considérée comme
une question de défense stratégique
dans le sens où il s'agit de libérer ces zones
qui avait été complètement isolées,
dans lesquelles vivaient les gens qui avaient été à l'origine, si vous voulez,
de 40 ans d'attentats, d'enlèvements
et d'assassinats.
Et soudain,
les enfants ont des ordinateurs portables connectés.
Ils ont fait un bond de géant.
Le changement est absolument monumental,
car il ne s'agit pas seulement de l'ouvrir,
mais de l'ouvrir sur le reste du monde.
Alors, oui, ils construisent des routes, oui, ils installent le téléphone,
oui, il y aura la télévision.
Mais les enfants de six à 12 ans
surfent sur Internet en espagnol et dans les langues locales,
donc les enfants grandissent
avec l'accès à l'information,
avec une fenêtre sur le reste du monde.
Avant, ils étaient isolés.
Chose intéressante, dans d'autres pays,
ce sera le ministre des Finances, qui voit
cela comme un moteur de la croissance économique.
Et ce moteur verra ses résultats dans 20 ans.
Cela ne va pas se faire, vous le savez, en un an,
mais c'est un changement important, profondément économique
et culturel
qui se passe au travers des enfants.
31 pays au total sont impliqués,
et dans le cas de l'Uruguay,
la moitié des enfants les ont déjà,
et d'ici le milieu de 2009,
tous les enfants en Uruguay auront un ordinateur portable --
un petit portable vert.
Maintenant, quels sont les premiers résultats ?
Parmi les résultats
qu'on retrouve dans chaque pays,
les enseignants disent
qu'ils n'ont jamais autant aimé enseigner,
et la compréhension écrite
mesurée par des tiers - et pas par nous - a progressé de façon fulgurante.
Ce que nous voyons probablement de plus important,
ce sont les enfants qui enseignent aux parents.
Ils possèdent les ordinateurs portables. Ils les emmènent à la maison.
Et alors quand j'ai rencontré trois enfants de ces écoles,
qui avaient voyagé toute la journée pour venir à Bogota,
l'un des trois enfants était venu avec sa mère.
Et la raison pour laquelle elle était venue avec sa mère
est que cette enfant de 6 ans
avait enseigné à sa mère
à lire et à écrire.
Sa mère n'était pas allée à l'école primaire.
Et c'est un tel renversement des rôles,
et un exemple si merveilleux
d'enfants qui sont des agents du changement.
Donc maintenant, pour terminer, les gens disent,
et pourquoi des ordinateurs portables ?
Les portables c'est du luxe ; c'est comme de leur donner des iPods. Non.
La raison pour laquelle il faut des ordinateurs portables
c'est que le mot-clé est éducation, pas ordinateur.
C'est un projet éducatif, pas un projet informatique.
Ils ont besoin d'apprendre à apprendre. Et puis, réfléchissez --
ils peuvent avoir, disons, 100 livres.
Dans un village, vous avez 100 ordinateurs portables,
chacun avec avec une collection différente de 100 livres,
et donc ce village a soudain 10 000 livres.
Vous et moi nous n'avions pas 10 000 livres quand nous étions à l'école primaire.
Parfois l'école est sous un arbre,
ou dans de nombreux cas, l'enseignant n'a étudié qu'au primaire,
donc il faut un modèle collaboratif d'apprentissage,
pas seulement construire plus d'écoles et former plus d'enseignants,
ce qu'il faut faire de toute façon.
Donc nous recommençons l'opération "un portable acheté, un offert"
L'an dernier, nous avons lancé un programme "un portable acheté, un offert",
et nous avons obtenu ainsi 100 000 ordinateurs portables.
que nous avons alors pu donner gratuitement.
Puisque c'était un ordinateur portable qui coûte zéro dollar,
nous pouvons nous rendre dans des pays qui ne peuvent pas du tout se le permettre.
C'est ce que nous avons fait. Nous sommes allés à Haïti,
nous sommes allés au Rwanda, en Afghanistan,
en Ethiopie et en Mongolie.
Des endroits qui ne sont pas des marchés,
en y semant les principes de
saturation, de connectivité, de jeune âge, etc.
Et ensuite nous pouvons vraiment déployer de grands nombres.
Alors voyez l'opération comme ceci :
voyez-la comme une vaccination des enfants
contre l'ignorance.
Et voyez l'ordinateur portable comme un vaccin.
Vous ne vaccinez pas quelques enfants.
Vous vaccinez tous les enfants dans une zone.